mr consistency starting pitcher big mike
pineda making his first appearance since
may 13th against the chicago white sox
he hits him that's right embrace him in
a different way first pitch swing for
cedric mullins in a good start for the
orioles on a sunny wednesday
mullins with a first pitch single off of
pineda
runner goes swung on and missed
ostidio's throw
is in time to get him
a one-hop throw and simmons is so good
around the bag
in terms of making the catch and getting
a tag i didn't think he had a shot just
being able to see
mullen's
great jump
trey with a walk yesterday on base for
the 12th straight game now tied with
vladimir guerrero jr major league lead
in rbis
hang a breaking ball tray out to left
field learn it gives it a look it is
long gone another rbi for trey and
another long ball
number 11 for mancini who jumps all over
pineda in the first
you know 102 miles per hour and that
ball uh firmly hit one nothing lead
here's a high fly center field
going back as ref snyder at the wall he
makes the catch and stewart just missed
another home run the orioles did get one
from trey mancini to take the first lead
and jorge lopez the numbers not a lot of
runs
one or less at seven out of his eight
starts
starting it out with kepler who sends 96
skyward
cedric mullins on the case
this one belted by polanco out to right
stewart on the run stewart makes the
play in a loud out for jorge polanco
yeah i think we're getting the idea that
uh polanco's a pretty good fastball
hitter
that one swung through at 98 lopez
overpowers cino and works around a
couple of walks in the first
swung on a miss he lost his helmet
wilkerson out on strikes two down
strike three and it is a quick one two
three inning
for big mike in the second
to the gap in left center field arnick's
got him on a into the gap and it bounces
over for a double
i'm going to hit his home run the other
day and it was a long one to straight
away center field
rap snyder on the ground to third base
franco is going to come home with it
larnick is out
nice defense an even better pitcher
and a fastball called strike three lopez
living on the outside
and two strikeouts for jorge through two
scoreless
outside fastball lead off walk chance
cisco
seventh pitch coming 3-2 in the dirt
so pineda who walks just two batters per
nine innings in his career
has walked the first two in the third
some terrific plate appearances for
cisco at the bottom
and a breaking ball got him two down
now he could go after santander and
maybe pitch himself out of this inning
[Music]
across the line near the tarp and zieny
nice job by pineda after walking the
first two batters he gets the next three
and it's still one nothing
and polanco turns on this one to right
field stewart at the wall he's got it
he hauls it in all facets of the game
before dj
2-1 fastball this ball
i mean the win may be blowing across
enough and maybe swirling a really nice
play by dj
shattered bad for cruz lopez looks it
off and a one two three third with a
little help from his friends
[Music]
another line drive imagine that
on 3-2 lopez paints
absolutely stuck it at the bottom of the
zone to larning his third strikeout and
another one two three
hall of famer
another
[Music]
you can throw 90 but you got to have
some type of deception
and with him being you know
a large human being with long arms long
legs he has very good deception so that
90
i'm guessing the appearance to the
hitter is probably
94.95 sometimes
came back to strike him out two now
big mike's in a good groove
and a laser to left center field headed
toward the gap kepler will hold up with
a single
third leadoff hit
for the twins the only hits that they've
gotten
fall four
and it'll be kiraloff's turn with two
men aboard
well miguel's to know six strikeouts in
this he's going to take his time
drill to center mullins going back
gone a three-run home run for miguel
ceno
his third in 11 advance
against jorge lopez
five straight strikeouts and then a
broken bat fly ball and then the payoff
at the end with a three-run home run
and a raw speed pitch gets strike three
two down
right down the middle of strike
duffy pitches around a two out walk an
effective seventh
popped up near second base
simmons
with catch
fighting the sun was almost like an
oakland kind of a sun here with the
sun almost straight overhead he made the
play one down
and
back to the fastball on a call third
strike
really good hey then for caleb
robles will come in he's been awfully
good as of late had the blown save in
cleveland but the twins won the ball
game anyway there's the quick pitch home
and trey sends it in the air to right
field kepler will watch it bounce off
the wall the orioles will bring the
tying run to the plate on a double from
trey mancini the o's first hit since the
first
mancini's at second two outs his hand
into the glove three balls two stripes
here comes
fastball hit on a line right center
field this plugs the alley and it
bounces and goes up against the wall
mancini scores from second base it's
another rbi for franco against roll
blaze it's now a one run game three to
two twins in the ninth
shattered bat
polanco to carol off and the twins
complete the three-game sweep
roblaise despite the doubles gets the
save
and the twins continue their good roll
to get this home stand started